what are the things that for you are
like off the table with regards to this
is too much this is too risky for me the
biggest one is like tread yeah the good
old Trend there's guys who literally
base their social media off that now
it's just like a meme of the gym culture
and I don't even think people realize
the impact that these jokes and memes
have on people coming up who just see
you constantly joking and talking about
saying you need more of it to be better
and feel stronger that's probably the
most toxic thing you can put in your
body I've done it in the past but I
don't anymore I just haven't touched it
in like five years why just the toxicity
it causes in your body it just comes in
it harms your kidneys your liver just
everything that takes your body to
process and go through it it's just not
natural it's not meant to be in your
body it makes you stronger people if you
say they feel like they're on top of the
world when they take it but to me that's
not really worth the health risk anymore